so much is left and I bought it today
like a human being should be in a body
bag if this is how much is left hello
today we're gonna talk about the FBI
versus Martin Luther King jr. during the
1960's J Edgar Hoover was the head of
the FBI he's an old man
he thought communists are gonna take
over America and I gotta get ready for
it meanwhile Maher luther king a
non-violent christian minister gives us
the greatest speech of the entire 20th
century i have a dream that we will live
in a fair society where you know it
doesn't matter what race you are you can
achieve anything you believe in like ten
other beautiful things and jagger hoover
sees a speech and says I have a dream
this is total communist stuff it all
makes so much sense when you think about
it like a crazy person
Jay guru verrat called a press
conference and Hoover tells these
reporters that he's invited who are all
women for some reason Martin Luther King
is the most dishonest man in America
one of Hoover's underlings is saying
babe you should be nice and Hoover's
like you I'm gonna tell the truth they
meet in j edgar Hoover's office Martin
Luther King says hey J Edgar Hoover I
love it everything you've ever done
maybe we could just be better teammates
so we can achieve peace throughout
America after this first two minutes
Jake Hoover decided dude now it's my
turn it's my turn to say what's on my
mind the FBI does this the FBI does that
the FBI is helping you here the FBI is
helping you there Amy just goes on and
on and on and on about how awesome the
FBI is and afterwards when if Martin
Luther King's friends calls him and says
what was it like meeting with Martin
Luther King I'm sorry I'm bet that's how
drunk I am okay what was it like meeting
with J Edgar Hoover and Martin Luther
King was like dude I'll tell you jr.
he's just not old man who talks too much
he's crazy
Jake guru ver was the thing to
everything that he said he was like what
the she's talking she might be even
though I just talked with them oh man's
on now these boss these these guys these
guys try to harass Martin Luther King
this FBI agent William Sullivan his
entire job is like mind Effie so he
decides like I gotta I gotta write a
letter dear Martin Luther King I'm a
black person just like you I've got a
white guy I think that you are a bad
person
you better kill yourself see the
attachment the attachment is a recording
of you having sex with lots of people
the end I'm black sin when this
mysterious package showed up Martin
Luther King's wife Coretta Scott King
listened to it it was like a mixtape
but the FBI had specially made every sex
act every embarrassing thing that Martin
Luther King had ever done and Martin
Luther King's like this is crazy
the FBI is trying to destroy my life
they try to give up they try to make him
give up his core beliefs Martin Luther
King decides like I'm gonna stick to
what I believe I don't care what you
guys do to me
Martin Luther King continues to fight
for what he believes in Hoover never
retired from the FBI he just sort of
slowed down I think that he was just
very upset
and anybody who has sex he thought it
was a real bad idea
didn't like it I'm gonna die now goodbye
[Music]
I'm handsome last notches I've ever been
in my life
[Music]